T
THANK YOU FOR PLAYING IT.
I'M LAURA INGRAHAM AND THIS IS
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" BACK IN
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"THE ANGLE."
CUTTING LOSSES.
THE GOAL WE SEND IS UNOBTAINABLE
OR THAT THE COST OF ACHIEVING IT
IS TOO HIGH.
INSTINCTIVELY WE FEEL LIKE
ENDING SOMETHING PREMATURELY MAY
BE AS A SIGN OF WEAKNESS AND
THEN QUITTING IS FOR LOSERS.
BUT ESPECIALLY IN POLITICS, THE
OPPOSITES OFTEN TRUE.
JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENT, THERE ARE
SADLY MANY AREAS WHERE AMERICA
NEEDS TO CUT THEIR LOSSES.
WE NEED TO CUT OUR LOSSES IN
UKRAINE.
IF YOU HADN'T NOTICED, THE
UKRAINIANS AREN'T WINNING.
OUR OWN NATION IS HURTING AND
WE'VE ALLOCATED MORE THAN
$53 BILLION AND COUNTING AND
HUMANITARIAN MILITARY AID TO
HELP THEM BEAT BACK THE
RUSSIANS.
BUT NOW?
HERE'S A HEADLINE.
PUTIN MAY WIN IN UKRAINE.
BUT THE REAL WAR IS JUST
STARTING.
RUSSIA RATHER THAN UKRAINE IS
WINNING THE WAR TOO.
DESPITE THAT, BIDEN THINK
SPENDING ALL THAT MONEY AND TIME
IS WORTH IT.
>> DEFENDING FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY WAS NOT GOING TO GO
WITHOUT COST FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
PAY A PRICE AS WELL IN THE COST
OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT,
HUMANITARIAN RELIEF, AND I
BELIEVE THEN AND NOW THE FREE
WORLD HAD NO CHOICE.
AMERICA COULD NOT STAND BY.
>> Laura: IT'S TIME TO CUT OUR
LOSSES BEFORE IT TURNS INTO
ANOTHER IRAQ OR AFGHANISTAN.
BLED DRY FOR YEARS AND YEARS
WITH NO VICTORY.
EUROPE IS IN POINTING OUT THE
WAY IT SHOULD.
AMERICA IS STILL THE BIGGEST
OVERALL CONTRIBUTOR WITH ABOUT
HALF OF COMMITMENTS IN UKRAINE
MADE BY THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S REMARKABLE THE U.S. ALONE
COMMITTED CONSIDERABLY MORE THAN
ALL THE E.U. COUNTRIES COMBINED.
WHOSE IMMEDIATE NEIGHBORHOOD THE
WAR IS RAGING.
BY THE WAY, SANCTIONS, NOT
WORKING.
IN FACT THEY'RE MAKING RUSSIA
EVEN RICHER.
MONEY IS POURING IN FROM CHINA
AND OTHER NATIONS.
RUSSIA'S OIL EXPORTS ARE
SOARING.
OOPS.
SECOND, IT'S LONG SINCE TIME WE
CUT OUR LOSSES IN CHINA.
LAST YEAR OUR TRADE DEFICIT WITH
THEM WAS OVER $350 BILLION.
WE KNOW THAT YOU SLAVE LABOR TO
MAKE EVERYTHING FROM SNEAKERS TO
COMPUTER CHIPS.
THEY LIED ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF
COVID.
WHY ARE WE DEPENDENT ON CHINA
FOR ANYTHING?
BIDEN OF COURSE IS MAKING THE
OPPOSITE COURSE AND POISED TO
LET THE TRUMP TERRORISTS GIVE US
SOME LEVERAGE AGAINST CHINA AND
SAVE SOME U.S. MANUFACTURERS.
IF SCOTT PAUL ON THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" THAT AN
AUTHORITARIAN STATE IS NO LONGER
AN ACCEPTABLE STATUS QUO.
WE SHOULD NOT ABANDON IMPORTANT
TRADE LEVERAGE TO SHAVE A
ROUNDING ERROR OF THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX.
WE NEED TO START DECOUPLING FROM
CHINA.
IMMEDIATELY.
THIRD, IT'S TIME TO CUT OUR
LOSSES WITH THE FOOLISH GREEN
OBSESSION.
THE DEMOCRATS TALK ABOUT HOW
GREAT TRANSITIONS CAN BE PAINFUL
AT TIMES.
WHAT YOU SEE UNDER BIDEN IS THE
PROSPERITY TO POVERTY.
AND FROM TO SERVITUDE.
AMERICANS JUST CAN'T AFFORD TWO
AND A HALF MORE YEARS OF HIGH
PRICES FOR GAS, FOOD, MORE
GOODS.
BIDEN MEANWHILE RESPONDS NOT
WITH MORE DRILLING, BUT WITH
MORE GIMMICKS.
>> THE FEDERAL GAS TAX FOR THE
NEXT 90 DAYS WE CAN BRING DOWN
THE PRICE OF GAS AND GIVE
FAMILIES JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
RELIEF.
THE SECOND ACTION I'M TAKING IS
CALLING ON STATES TO EITHER
SUSPEND THE GAS TAX AS WELL OR
FIND OTHER WAYS TO DELIVER
RELIEF.
>> Laura: DON'T YOU LIKE THE
THING ON THE WALL BEHIND HIM?
>> MY MESSAGE IS SIMPLE.
TO THE COMPANY IS RUNNING GAS
STATIONS AND SETTING THE PRICES
AT THE PUMP, BRING DOWN THE
PRICE YOU'RE CHARGING AT THE
PUMP.
DO IT NOW, DO IT TODAY.
>> Laura: THAT'S A WEIRD VOICE
HE USES.
IT DOES HE NOT REALIZE THAT MOST
GAS STATIONS ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES?
A LOT OF THEM ARE MOM AND TOP.
IS HE JUST STUPID OR PLAIN
STUPID AT THIS POINT?
IT'S HARD TO TELL.
BUT THEN AGAIN, THE PRESS THINGS
WE ALL COMPLAIN TOO MUCH.
>> IS A GREAT DEAL OF AMERICANS
WHERE IT'S UNCOMFORTABLE THAT
THEY ARE SPENDING MORE
BUT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO GO
UNDER.
I NEED YOU TO CALM DOWN AND BACK
OFF BIG IT FEEDS INTO THE FEAR
AND INTO PEOPLE MAKING DECISIONS
THAT CREATES THE VERY THING THAT
THEY ARE FEARFUL OF.
IF YOU ARE IN THAT CATEGORY,
STOP IT!
>> Laura: SHE'S AN ACTUAL
JOURNALIST FOR
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
WE ALSO NEED TO CUT OUR LOSSES
IN THE MILITARY.
THINGS ARE SO BAD WITH RACE AND
INDOCTRINATION AMONG OUR
SOLDIERS THAT EVEN WEST POINT IS
LOSING ITS ALLURE.
TURNING TO JUDICIAL WATCH, WE
SEE THE TRAINING MATERIALS THAT
INCLUDE THESE GEMS AND IN ORDER
TO UNDERSTAND RACIAL INEQUALITY,
IT'S NECESSARY TO ASSESS
WHITENESS.
IT GOES ON TO SAY WHITENESS IS A
LOCATION OF STRUCTURAL ADVANTAGE
OF RACE PRIVILEGE.
DO YOU ALL REALIZE THIS NONE GES
FUNDED BY REPUBLICAN VOTES?
NO, CUTTING OUR LOSSES MEANS
PERFORMING OUR MILITARY BACK TO
ITS ORIGINAL PURPOSE AND ROLE AS
A FIGHTING FORCE.
FIFTH, IT'S TIME TO CUT OUR
LOSSES WITH ALL THINGS COVID.
IF WE ARE UP TO BIDEN, THE
GOVERNMENT WOULD BORROW HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS MORE FOR
TESTING WE DON'T NEED AND
VACCINES FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS THAT MOST PARENTS DON'T
WANT.
JUST A MONTH INTO HIS
PRESIDENCY, THE PRESIDENT WAS
TALKING A VERY GOOD GAME.
>> I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT ONCE
WE BE COVID, WE ARE GOING DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN.
>> Laura: AND NOW, 18 MONTHS
LATER HE'S LOOKING FOR MORE
MONEY.
COVID IS STILL CIRCULATING AND
HE MADE AN OMINOUS REFERENCE.
>> WE NEED MORE MONEY, BUT NOT
JUST MORE MONEY FOR VACCINES FOR
CHILDREN EVENTUALLY, WE NEED TO
GO THROUGH
--
>> Laura: I'M GOING TO SAY
THIS IN A WAY BIDEN FANS CAN
UNDERSTAND.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE CONTROL!
DEFUND ANY REMAINING VAX
MANDATES ESPECIALLY THE PUSH FOR
FAXING MALL CHILDREN
THEN TYRELL INDUSTRIAL COMPLEX
NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED FROM
THE NIH, FAUCHER, THE NIA V.
BECAUSE AMERICANS NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER THE SCIENTISTS HAVE BEEN
COMPROMISED FROM BIG PHARMA OR
BY THEIR RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHINA.
WE NEED TO CUT OUR LOSSES ON
CRIME AND BY DEFEATING THE
LIBERAL D.A. ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
IN SAN FRANCISCO CAN BOOST THE
BOMB, SO CAN OTHER CITIES.
IT'S TIME FOR BILLIONAIRES WHO
ARE SANE TO FUND NEW CAMPAIGNS
TO OUST ALL OF THE LEFT
WING NUTS WHO ELIMINATED CASH
BAIL AND GENERALLY MADE OUR
STREETS MORE DANGEROUS.
THIS IS A MATTER OF LIFE AND
DEATH AT THIS POINT.
WE NEED A CUT OUR LOSSES WITH
THE G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT.
THOSE DINOSAURS LUMBERING AROUND
MORE INTERESTED IN DOING DEALS
WITH BIDEN THEN STAYING TRUE TO
THE CONSTITUTION.
LAST YEAR THEY SIGNED ON TO AN
IDIOTIC INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND
NOW MANY OF THE SAME SENATORS
ARE SIGNING ON TO A GUN-CONTROL
BILL.
14 REPUBLICANS AND ALL LED BY
JOHN CORNYN OF TEXAS.
THEY ARE GIVING BIDEN THE
VICTORY AND INFRINGING ON THE
RIGHTS OF LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS.
THE LEGISLATION IS 80 PAGES LONG
AND LAST NIGHT, A VOTE WAS
CALLED JUST HOURS AFTER THE
TEXTBOOK WAS RELEASED.
IT'S A COMPLETE TRAVESTY AND
IT'S ONE MORE STEP ON THE ROAD
TO A GUN BAN.
MORE ON THIS LATER.
AND FINALLY, AMERICANS NEED TO
CUT THEIR LOSSES WITH THE PARTY
IN POWER.
WE KNOW DEMOCRATS ARE IN CHARGE,
AND THEY, NOT VLADIMIR PUTIN,
ARE DESTROYING ALMOST EVERYTHING
WE LOVE TODAY.
AMERICANS ARE GETTING POORER BY
THE DAY AND COST OF EVERYTHING
IS GOING UP.
EXCEPT FOR ONE THING.
THE DNC SLASHED THE PRICE OF A
KAMALA HARRIS PHOTO UP FROM
$50,000 TO $5,000.
WHAT A BARGAIN.
WHEN AMERICA IS HURTING, WHEN
POLICIES AND PLANS AREN'T
PANNING OUT, IT'S TIME TO
SWITCH.
THE SWAMP IN D.C. IS HOME TO A
VARIETY OF MONSTERS, LOBBYISTS,
POLITICIANS, CONSULTANTS